طوال نحو سبعين عاما ارتبطت السعوديه
واندونيسيا بعلاقات قويه عندما خلالها
اوجه التعاون في كافه الاصعده فمن ذو نشاه
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بينهما في العام
1948 ربط البلدين تاريخ طويل من العلاقات
حيث جمعتهما روابط دينيه واجتماعيه
فاندونيسيا تعد موطن اكبر عدد من السكان
المسلمين في العالم اما اقتصاديا فتجمعهما
عضويه مجموعه ال 20 فلكل البلدين اقتصاد
متين يعد من بين الاقوى عالميا حيث ان
اقتصاد السعوديه هو الاعلى نموا في مجموعه
العشرين واندونيسيا واحده من افضل الاسواق
الناشئه اداء في العالم وفي مجال التعاون
التجاري تعد السعوديه شركه تجاريه الاول
الاندونيسيا في الشرق الاوسط حيث تجاوز
حجم التبادل التجاري بين البلدين خلال
العام 2021 حاجزا 18 مليار ريال كما تقدر
نسبه الن مقارنه بالعام 2020 ب 37% فيما
بلغ التبادل التجاري خلال الخمس سنوات
الماضيه اكثر من 92 مليارات وعلى الصعيد
الانساني والاغاثي دعمت السعوديه عبر مركز
الملك سلمان للاغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه
اندونيسيا خلال الفتره بين عامي 2005 و22
بمشاريع باكثر من 72 مليون دولار في
قطاعات منها الصحه والتعليم والامن
الغذائي
[موسيقى]